So other than the description, hm, it
looks like you changed style1 to style!
.
>> [LAUGH] Huh, oh, yeah, I did do that.
That wasn't intentional.
I was going to change my stylesheet, but
then at the last minute,
I decided not to.
I think I made a mistake.
>> Yeah, sounds like a typo.
So what happens if you fix that?
>> Let's try it.
Cool, it worked.
>> Great.
>> You know,
it's kind of annoying doing it manually.
Is there any way to get
the computer to help me?
>> Yeah, there are some built in tools
that can automatically compare files.
I'll go over how to
use these in a minute.
>> Good thing I saved the old one then.
>> Yeah, I'm glad you did.
In a bigger project, having an old
version saved can mean that you
spend a few minutes finding
your mistake instead of hours.